قالت اوكرانيا ان روسيا كثفت هجماتها على
العاصمه كييف وعلى مختلف جبهات القتال
شرقيه وجنوبيه وشماليه البلاد ودعت الغرب
الى تقويه الدفاعات الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك
طائرات اف 16 بينما قالت روسيا التي اكدت
تمسكها بتحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا انكيا
هاجمت مقاطعه بيل غورود التي طالب حاكمها
بضم خركيز لتامين المقاطعه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تكثيف روسيا
هجماتها بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره على
كياث وتصعيد اوكرانيا في مقاطعه بلغورود
الروسيه ما تعقيدات التي يمكن ان تضيفها
مطالبه كياف الغرب بتعزيز دفاعاتها الجويه
ودعوه حاكم
الى المقاطعه وما المسارات المحتمله للحرب
في ضوء تاكيد الكريم
وتمسكه بتحقيقها وتاكيد اوكرانيا ضروره
انهاء الوجود الروسي على اراضيها
[موسيقى]
منخر كيف في الشمال الى اوديسا في الجنوب
ومن مناطق سيطراتها في محافظه
شرقا وحتى كييف غربا تقول الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان روسيا تكثف
هجماتها بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره او
عبر الهجمات المباشره في مناطق التماس
وتضيف كييف التي تؤكد تصديها لكل هذه
الهجمات الروسيه ان ايقاف هذه الهجمات لن
يتم العبره تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك تزويد الغرب
لاوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16
في موسكو التي اكدت ان اهداف ما تسميها
عمليتها العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا لم
تتغير وانه لابد من تحقيقها كامله قال
حاكم بيلجورود الروسيه على الحدود مع
اوكرانيا ان قصفا اوكرانيا استهدف مؤسستين
صناعيتين في المقاطعه اوقع اربع ضحايا
اضاف حاكم المقاطعه التي افادت وسائل
اعلام روسيه بتعرض عدد من قراها لقصف
اوكراني ب30 قذيفه مدفعيه وهاون ان حل
مشكله القصف واستهداف المقاطعه المتكرر
يكمن في ضم مقاطعه خركاف الى
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من كييف اوليكس
منك مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق
من موسكو معنا رولاند بيتجاموف الباحث
والمحلل السياسي ومن عمان ينضم الينا
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكم جميعا سنبدا معك
لواء فايز المعارك اذا تشتد في الميدان
وبين الطرفين لماذا ما الذي يحدث
هناك جمله اسباب لكلا الجانبين هناك تصعيد
من كلا الجانبين ولكل اسبابه ابدا بالجانب
الروسي الجانب الروسي
السبب الاول يتمثل في الرد على التصعيد
الاوكراني والتصعيد الاوكراني كشف في بعض
الحالات نقاط الضعف والوهن في الجيش
الروسي على سبيل المثال عندما تم مسيرتين
رغم اسقاطهم هاجمت الكرمليد
ثم قصف ماريوبل
قصف متكرر على شبه جزيره القرم ومناسفا
ستوبل قصف مصافي نفط قصف قاعده انجلز
تنفيذ عمليه بريه داخل بيجرود وبالتالي
هذه العمليات المتتاليه كانها كشفت عن
عيوب معينه في المنظومه العسكريه الروسيه
فكان لزاما على روسيا ان ترد على هذا
وتحاول ان تثبت قدرات وانها لا تزال الرقم
الصعب والجيش رقم اثنين الامر الرد
المنفتح اليوم ربما في هذا الاطار كان
الاستهداف المتكرر لكياف وبعنف واليوم ما
حدث هو اطلاق مسيرات في خلال النهار ماذا
وراء ذلك ايضا باعتقادك ما الاهداف
العسكريه الروسيه من وراء ذلك
ساتي على ذكر ذلك الان السبب الثاني
الرئيسي هناك الحديث المتواتر والمكثف حول
هجوم الربيع والان الحديث عن هجوم الصيف
وبالتالي يعني هذا الهجوم اصبح كانه مشاهد
عيانا ولكن لم يبدا بعد هذا الهجوم لابد
لروسيا ان تجهضه واجهاض ليس فقط بعد بدء
الهجوم لابد من التدخل في التحذيرات
الاساسيه سواء على مستوى البعد التخطيطي
وقصف القياده العامه وصانعي القرار وهيئات
الركن للمخططه او على المستوى الميداني
باستهداف المستودعات وشبكات الامداد
وشبكات الرادار والبنى التحتيه اذا هناك
جمله من الاسباب للجانب الروسي تفرض عليه
ان يساعد الجانب الاوكراني لديه كذلك
اسبابه تختصرها في منها التدخل في
المنظومه الدفاعيه الروسيه وفرض واقع
ميداني جديد مثل عمليه بلغرود او العمليه
على مهاجمه مصفاه النفط على الحدود
البلاروسيه
ومحاوله ارسال رساله ان الذراع الاوكراني
كذلك طويل ونستطيع ان نتدخل في تحضيراتكم
الدفاعيه وهجومنا اتي وسوف يحقق اهدافه
اجابه على سؤالك لماذا كيف هناك تسلسل
تناسلي لاهميه الاهداف اولا نبدا بالاهداف
التي تصنف على انها مراكز ثقل وهنا مركز
الثقل اي هدف يعتبر مركز ثقل ياخذ ابعادا
سياسيه وعسكريه وامنيه واقتصاديه وبالتالي
مركز الثقل رقم واحد في كل دول العالم
العاصمه مكان القرار السياسي مكان القرار
العسكري مكان القرار الامني
وعصب الاقتصاد الرئيسي وبالتالي
يجب ان تكون الهدف رقم واحد لروسيا لماذا
لانها اذا نجحت واليوم الحديث كان عن
مناطق ذات حساسيه عاليه ماذا تعني لم نعرف
ما هي هذه المنطقه ولكن هل هي المناطق
التي يتواجد فيها اصحاب القرار السياسي
والعسكري والامني قد يكون ذلك اذا هذا
الهجوم هذا الهجوم هو يجب ان يكون ضمن
دائره التوقف واضح فايز ابقى معي اذهب الى
رولاند بيجاموف من موسكو سيد رولاند ماذا
حققت روسيا من وراء هذه الهجمات المتكرره
والعنيفه التي تشتد عنفا في الاونه
الاخيره على الاراضي الاوكرانيه في نقاط
مختلفه وهل فعلا تسعى كما يقول اللواء
فايز الدويري هل تسعى لص
د اي هجوم مضاد عليها قبل ان يبدا
مساء الخير تحياتي لك ال سي والديك الكريم
المتواضعه قبل كل شيء هذا الهجوم
المتتاليه وقسو الكيف ومعناه هو الصيد على
صواريخ بيتريوت الامريكيه نعلم ان هناك
بطاريتين من بيتريوت وايضا هناك راجمات
الناس
والجيش الروسي يبدو ان يريد ان يحدد مواقع
تموضع هذه البطاريات منها مخططات التحكم
ومنصات الاطلاق
وكما علمنا انه هناك الولايات المتحده
بعثه
النموذج الجديد من بيتريوت ومن خلال هذه
المعركه يجارب الجانب الامريكي ان يعرف
المواصفات الصواريخ الروسيه هو معامله
الصواريخ فرط صوتيه مثلا من نوع كنجار
وغيرها وايضا
الجيش الروسي يريد بهذا القصف في الدرجه
الاولى ان
يحدد هذه المواقع ويدمر قدرات كيف للدفاع
الجوي ثانيا هناك العامل المعنوي
السيكولوجي التاثير على سكان العاصمه كييف
لان الحجمات اول مره شاهدنا
وتخدث بهذه الكثافه
في الفجر وايضا في النهار
وفي غياب الخلول السياسيه لهذه الصراع لا
بد من ان نشهد مثل هذا التصعيد وايضا
تفضل مثلا عن البيت وهناك بطبيعه الحال
اهداف اخرى ولكن هذه الاه داف التي يتم
الحديث عنها من الناحيه العسكريه هل
استطاعت موسكو ان تحققها لان الطرف
الاوكراني يتحدث عن ان الدفاعات تصدت
لمعظم المسيرات وصواريخ
لابد ان
نصطم مثل هذه
التعقيدات والتصريحات وبيانات من الجانب
الاوكراني لان الجانب الاوكراني لا طبعا
هو اسقط عدد كبير من الاهداف وهنا يجب
الاشاره الى معظم من هذه الاحداث هي
المسيرات رخيصه ليست لها القيمه يعني
اهداف خاطئه اما الروس التكتيك للهجوم هو
اولا يضربون ويكسفون ويستخدمون السياره
المسيرات الرخيصه
وبعدما عرفوا الاماكن بالتخديد حيث هناك
مناطق
لتموودت فيه مثلا
الاطلاق تضرب هذه المواقع كما حدث اليوم
في مطار جولاني بالقرب من هناك
اعمده من الدخان وغيرها من الامور منك
ماذا عن الهجمات الاوكرانيه التي تتكرر
على ماذا عن الاهداف من وراء ذلك
هذه
الهجمات في بوقره
نظمتها مجموعتين
انشاها مواطنين روس ومن المفهوم ان هذه
الهجمات قد رتبت مع الطرف
الاوكراني ولكن القوات الاوكرانيه الرسميه
لم تشترك في هذه العمليات واحد هذه
الاهداف او الهدف الاهم هو التاثير النفسي
على الاداره الروسيه والمجتمع الروسي وهذا
يظهر ضعف
القوات البريه الروسيه وعدم قدره روسيا
على الحفاظ على النظام في تلك المناطق
لذلك اذا كان عدد قليل من الاشخاص
استطاعوا ان يجتاحوا الاراضي على 30 كيلو
متر ثم العوده بسلام هذا يثبت ضعف روسيا
ويثبت ان لديها الكثير من نقاط الضعف وهذا
وهذه رساله لروسيا ان تعتني بشانها
الداخلي وليس بالدول الاخرى ولكن
المسؤولون الروسي يؤكدون ان من يقف وراء
هذه الهجمات هم الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي انطلاقا من ذلك على تخشى
اوكرانيا من ان يؤثر ذلك على علاقتها مع
الغرب على الدعم دول الغربيه
بالاسلحه خصوصا وان
اغلبيه هذه الدول كانت طالبت او كانت
عارضت ان يتم استهداف بالاسلحه المؤمنه
لاوكرانيا ان يتم استهداف الاراضي الروسيه
نعم فعلا هناك اتفاقات بين
كييف وبين الشركاء الغربيين هذا الاتفاق
عن ان الاسلحه الغربيه لن تستخدم في ضربات
على الاراضي الروسيه
وعندما نقصد المناطق الروسيه نعني المناطق
المعترف بها دوليا لذلك القرم والدمباس لا
يدخل في هذه المناطق لذلك الاعمال التي
حدثت في برجراف
حيث ظهرت سيارات هامرز
هذه السيارات كانت قد استولى عليها
المواطنين الروس المعرضون من القوات
الروسيه لذلك الحديث عن ان هناك تدخل من
المخابرات
الاوكرانيه حتى وان لم تعترف اوكرانيا
فهذا شيء واضح طيب سنسال في هذه النقطه
السيد رولان بيجاموف ولكن قبل ذلك اريد ان
اعود الى اللواء فايز الدويري واساله عن
الاسلحه الان اوكرانيا امام هذه الهجمات
المكثفه التي تتعرض لها تقول نريد المزيد
من تقويه لدفاعاتنا ما الذي يمكن ان تمنحه
دول الغرب بعد
يعني تقريبا السقف عالي جدا الذي قدم بدءا
من الباتروريت لكن الاعداد غير كافيه لا
شمس هناك تقريبا 14 15 نوع من الدفاعات
الجويه قدمت من مختلف الدول الاوروبيه
بدءا من استنكر وانتهاء في باتريوت باك 3
مرورا
بصواريخ فرنسيه بريطانيه المانيه بلجيكيه
اذا هناك 14 15 نوع لكن المشكله لا تكمل
في الانواع ولكن تكمن في الاعداد وبالتالي
هي تطلب المزيد من مما ارسل لها هي لو
اتيح لها تطلب عشر بطاريات باك 3 باتريوت
لكن امريكا قدمت بطاريه والمانيا قدمت
بطاريه وهل يمكن ان تقدم بطاريات اخرى ام
سيتم تقديم اسلحه اخرى ليس بالضروره لانه
التقارير واحده تكلف مليار دولار البطاريه
الواحده تكلف مليار دولار وبالتالي لا
يعقل ان تقدم بطاريات باتريوت اضافيه
باعداد كبيره كما تطلب اذا يتم الذهاب الى
ناس يتم الذهاب الى ماء الاسلحه مديء
الدفاعات الجويه ذات المدى القصير
والمتوسط وبالتالي ستعود المعادله الى
اسلحه اقل فاعليه لان هذه الاسلحه مكلفه
للغايه وليست متاحه ليست متاحه يعني ايضا
التي صنعت منها محدوده ماذا عن الاب سته
عشر لواء فايز هل يمكن بسرعه ان يؤمن هذا
الموضوع لاوكرانيا ويعني كيف
يتم التعامل مع هذا السلاح في الميدان
بالنظر الى هذه الهجمات كما تحدث يعني
الان هل سيتم تامينه بسرعه هذا الاجابه
تعتمد على اجراءات على ارض الواقع ليس
المهم ان ترسل الطائرات الطائرات حتى ترسل
لا بد من تجهيز البنيه التحتيه اللازمه
لهذه الطائرات لتعمل بكفاءه وتكون امنه
ولا يمكن تدميرها مباشره اذا يعني كان
هناك توجه وحديث ان ترسل هذه الطائرات
وحتى عندما ترسل ان توزع على القواعد
العسكريه وبصوره مخفيه بمعدل طائرتين الى
ثلاثه في كل قاعده اذا هذا رقم واحد اثنين
هل الطيارين جاهزين هل المنظومه طائره اف
16 كل ساعه طيران للطائره تحتاج الى 16
ساعه صيانه وبالتالي ليس من السهول
القول بان اوكرانيا جاهزه لاستقبال جاهز
الاستقبالها يبقى الان استعمالها هذه
طائره تف الجوي وطائره معترضه وقائد
وطائره اسناد قريب هذه تواجه الطائرات
المهاجمه وتساند القوات المتحركه ولكن
استخدامها في طور مواجهه صواريخ فرض صوتيه
اعتقد ان هذه المعادله غير موجوده في
الثقافه العسكريه الحاليه
اريد ان اسمع ردك على هذا الموضوع الذي
يتحدث به اكثر من مسؤول اوكرانيا عن ان
الهجمات التي تحدث في داخل روسيا في بلغو
تحديدا تقف وراءها مجموعات روسيه معارضه
فيما يتعلق هذه الهجمات اول شيء يجب ان
نعلمه وندركه هو ان هذه الهجمات نقطه
الانطلاق لهذه الهجمات هي اراضي اوكرانيا
وليست اراضي روسيا لا توجد في روسيا
المقاومه الداخليه او الموارده الداخليه
مصلخه اذا هذه الهجمات هي تخت اشراف
مديريه عامه للمخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه
وتنفس
بتنسيق معها وباسليها امريكيه وهذا الشيء
على فكره بالمناسبه لا تجيبه الولايات
المتحده لان بالفعل كانت هناك السيارات
المدرعه الامريكيه استخدمت في هذا
الهجوم على
هذه الحمله والتي نتيجه
المقاطعه يدعو الى ضم خارج اليها
لحسم هذا الموضوع
هذا هو هذا هو السؤال وانا في اعتقادي رد
فعل حاكم هو بالفعل كان ان فئه قبل كل شيء
لان هناك هذه المنطقه المناطق الخدوديه
بين روسيا واوكرانيا هناك السكان نسيج
مختلط يعني العائله الاخ يعيش في روسيا
واخته شقيقته في اوكرانيا
لذلك
الشعب هناك
يستقبل مثل هذه
الاختاس
بحساسيه عاليه ولذلك كان هو رد الفعل اما
بالنسبه الردود الفعل العسكريه
والسياسيه سياسيا قبل كل شيء هذا هو نتيجه
التنازلات التي قدمت للجانب الاوكراني في
اسطنبول في العام الماضي عندما كانت هناك
ما يطلق عليه بخطوه حسن الروسيه وانسحاب
القوات الروسيه المواجهه مفاجئ من ذواخر
منسومه ومن مناطق اخرى ثم تركوا هذه
الحدود دون الحمايه اللازمه والان يتم
اتخاذ الاجراءات في اطار مثلا هناك خطط
لمكافحه الارهاب والقياده روسيه تعتقد انه
حاليا هذه التدابير كافيه الا تخشى
اوكرانيا من ان هذه الهجمات قد تجلب عليها
يعني مزيد من المشاكل في تلك المناطق
تحديدا في خاركيف على غرار ما حدث في
اقليم دومباس
من الصعب ان نتخيل اي نتائج قد تكون اكثر
سوءا من
روسيا بالنسبه
للمزحه التي قام بها عمده بلجراد او
اعلانه العاطفي اعتقد انه يعلم جيدا ان
روسيا قبل عام حاولت ان تستعمر خاركوف
وانت تضمها ولكن من هناك قامت القوات
الاوكرانيه بصد جميع الجنود
الروس ولذلك هناك معارك مستمره بين
الاراضي الاوكرانيه والروسيه اما بالنسبه
لما قيل عن حسن النيه وعن سحب القوات
الروسيه ملكيه فيجب ان نقول ان القوات
الروسيه هدمت شرها هزيمه في تلك المناطق
واضطروا للانسحاب وهم ينسحبوا حتى الان من
خرسون واوكرانيا
كل ثقه تقوم بتحرير اراضيها اما الرد
الروسي فنحن نراه اليوم ويوميا وفي كل
ليله بالضربات الصاروخيه على العاصمه في
كيف اما انظمه باتريون اثبتت فعاليه عاليه
جدا مدهشه واليوم في النهار من من 37
صاروخ تقريبا كل الصواريخ دمرت لذلك روسيا
الان ليس لديها ما تقوم به الا الاسلحه
التكتيكيه النوويه
لديها كمساعده وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
السابق ضيفنا من كيف وشكرا لرولاند
بيتجاموف الباحث والمحلل السياسي من موسكو
ولواء فايز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من عمان
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]